so Tim Scott announces he's running for president
uh in the Republican primary I don't think he has
any shot at winning he's polling 1.8 percent
Donald Trump welcomed it and we know that the
reason Trump welcomes Scott running is Trump does
better in polling the more candidates there are
dividing up the non-trump votes so Trump's
glad for it the other people that seem to be
glad about it are the Fox and Friends crew Steve
Ducey and Ainsley Earhart and Brian Kilmeade now
Ainsley Earhart is particularly excited about
this she's from South Carolina and that may
be a factor here but they seem to just be gushing
and I think part of it is Ainsley Earhart herself
is from South Carolina and so is Tim Scott
and then on the other hand I think they're
desperate for someone other than trump it really
doesn't seem like the scientist has what it takes
so maybe they're interested in Tim Scott and
they say don't underestimate him by starting
at home yeah he's a really nice guy I love South
Carolina and what's ironic he's he's positive he's
mild-mannered he's seeking to form a coalition
of traditional conservatives and Evangelical
Christianity and moderate sounds great Ainsley
please send it down Republicans yeah they're
just screaming hello what's going on Sarah what
he is now a rock star in that area no bitterness
this is how far Charleston has come he's got 22
million dollars he's got a Super PAC that's got
13 million dollars anyone who dismisses Tim Scott
it's uh you will regret that well right I don't
know why you'll regret it but you will he's got
22 million it sounds it sounds like 98.2 percent
of Republican voters are currently dismissing Tim
Scott I was in his uh treasury that according to
the SEC is the most any presidential candidate
has ever had at this point wow you know I almost
I almost feel bad because I feel like almost Tim
Scott's too good for politics there you go he's
too good of a candidate he's too good of a guy
uh is this weird or is it just me he's such a
great guy to be a preacher and he did put out an
ad that is now running and Elon Musk came out and
said that is a great ad there you go that clip
from decoding Fox News which who continues to do
great work on Twitter um the Elon musk's seal of
approval uh and we know we know everything Elon
Musk touches turns to Gold of course Tesla stock
down about 80 percent and Twitter in shambles so
Tim Scott don't underestimate him as 98.2 percent
of current Republican primary voters are doing and
uh we will see how Tim Scott does in the meantime
let's talk a little bit about DeSantis Trump